CRISIS.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
TONIGHT WE'RE GOING TO TELL YOU
ABOUT TWO DIFFERENT ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION STORIES FROM TWO
DIFFERENT STATES.
BOTH DEMONSTRATE HOW POLITICIANS
ARE PUTTING AMERICAN HEALTH AND
WELL-BEING AT RISK.
THIS IS NOT HYPERBOLE.
THE RAMIFICATIONS, IF THIS IS
NOT ADDRESSED, ARE VERY SERIOUS.
PERHAPS DEADLY SERIOUS.
FIRST, IN CALIFORNIA, A
SANCTUARY STATE.
WE GET A GLIMPSE OF WHAT TYPE OF
AMERICA WE HAVE TO LOOK FORWARD
TO IF DEMOCRATS TAKE BACK THE
WHITE HOUSE IN 2020.
SCARCE RESOURCES ARE BEING
LAVISHED ON THE GROWING NUMBER
OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS IN THAT
STATE WHILE THE SITUATION GETS
MORE DIRE BY THE DAY FOR
CALIFORNIA'S HOMELESS POPULATIO
POPULATION.
NOW, IT'S SO BAD THAT NORMALLY
SANGUINE PEOPLE LIKE DR. DREW
PINSKY, AN L.A. RESIDENT
HIMSELF, ARE ISSUING THEMSELVES
DIRE WARNINGS.
>> TUBERCULOSIS IS EXPLODING.
WE DON'T HAVE A RODENT CONTROL
PROGRAM.
SANITATION IS BREAKING DOWN.
WE'LL HAVE A TYPHUS OUTBREAK THE
SUMMER.
I AM HEARING THAT YOU BIONIC
PLAGUE IS LIKELY.
IT'S ALREADY HERE.
THE ENTIRE POPULATION IS AT RIS
RISK.
>> Laura: THE LIBERAL
POLITICIANS IN CALIFORNIA --
>> DISGUSTINGLY NEGLIGENT.
I WAS DRIVING OVER AND I
THOUGHT, DO THEY WANT THE PEOPLE
ON THE STREETS TO DIE?
THEY DON'T CARE IF THEY ALL
DIED?
>> Laura: THAT'S COMPASSION.
BEYOND NEGLIGENCE.
AND IN APRIL, KAISER HEALTH NEWS
REPORTED THAT DEATHS IN THE
HOMELESS POPULATION JUST IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY ALONE JUMPED
76% IN THE PAST FIVE YEARS.
MORE THAN 900 DIED LAST YEAR
ALONE.
NOW HOW CAN THIS BE ALLOWED TO
HAPPEN?
WHEN MILLIONS OF ILLEGALS IN THE
STATE ENJOY NOT ONLY LEGAL
SANCTUARY BUT ALSO THE RIGHT TO
APPLY FOR THINGS LIKE IN-STATE
TUITION, DRIVERS LICENSES, AND
STATE-FUNDED OF COURSE
HEALTH CARE FOR THEIR CHILDREN.
THEN OVER THE WEEKEND, WE
LEARNED THAT CALIFORNIA HAS GONE
FROM SANCTUARY STATE FOR
DREAMERS TO JUST BEING A SUCKER
STATE FOR AMERICANS.
THEY JUST ANNOUNCED STATE BUDGET
DEAL WILL NOW GIVE HEALTH CARE
BENEFITS TO MANY ADULT ILLEGALS
TOO.
THOSE BETWEEN THE AGES OF 19 AND
25 WILL NOW BE ELIGIBLE FOR
CALIFORNIA'S MEDICAID PROGRAM
KNOWN AS MEDICAL.
>> EVERY PERSON SHOULD HAVE
ACCESS TO QUALITY AFFORDABLE
HEALTH CARE.
POLITICIANS AND JUDGES MAY TURN
BACK OUR -- WE WILL NEVER WAVER
IN OUR PURSUIT OF GUARANTEED
HEALTH CARE FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
>> Laura: HE SAID HE WOULD DO
IT AND THEY ARE DOING IT FOR THE
PRICE TAG IS ESTIMATED TO BE
98 MILLION BUCKS ANNUALLY.
THINK THOSE HOMELESS PEOPLE
INCLUDING HOMELESS VETS MIGHT BE
ABLE TO USE THAT MONEY?
REMEMBER, 98 MILLION.
SINCE THE DEMOCRATS DO THE MATH,
THE REAL COST IS PROBABLY DOUBLE
OR TRIPLE.
DO YOU REMEMBER WHAT THEY
ESTIMATED THE ILL-FATED BULLET
TRAIN WILL COST ON HOW THEY
WOULD PAY FOR THAT?
WELL, HOW THEY'RE GOING TO PAY
FOR THIS BY THE WAY, BY TAXING
CITIZENS WHO DON'T HAVE
HEALTH INSURANCE.
IN OTHER WORDS, REVIVING THE
PENALTY OF OBAMACARE.
REMEMBER THAT?
NOW EVEN LIBERALS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA SEEM TO BE AT A
BREAKING POINT.
JUST A FEW MONTHS BACK, SINGER
AND PERFORMER SHARE WHO
CONSIDERS BASHING FROM A MORAL
IMPERATIVE SOUNDED OFF HERSELF
SINGING THE TWEET "I UNDERSTANDH
SINGING THE TWEET "I UNDERSTANDL
SINGING THE TWEET "I UNDERSTANDI
SINGING THE TWEET "I UNDERSTANDG
SINGING THE TWEET "I UNDERSTANDM
SINGING THE TWEET "I UNDERSTANDA
SINGING THE TWEET "I UNDERSTANDT
SINGING THE TWEET "I UNDERSTANDS
BUT MY CITY LOS ANGELES ISN'T
TAKING CARE OF ITS OWN.
WHAT ABOUT THE 50,000 PLUS
CITIZENS WHO LIVE ON THE
STREETS, PEOPLE WHO LIVE BELOW
THE POVERTY LINE AND HUNGRY?
IF MY STATE CAN'T TAKE CARE OF
ITS OWN, MANY ARE VETS, HOW CAN
IT TAKE CARE OF MORE?"
I NEVER THOUGHT I WOULD AGREE
WITH CHER BUT I AGREE WITH CHER.
MOST OF THE REPORTING IS FRAMED
THIS WAY.
I LOVE THIS.
IT'S FRAMED, AS THE GOLDEN STATE
SENDING A MESSAGE TO THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
OR CALIFORNIA'S EFFORT TO
DISTANCE ITSELF FROM TRUMP.
BUT THE BETTER FRAMING, THE MORE
ACCURATE FRAMING WOULD BE
"CALIFORNIA, WITH ITS HIGH
TAXES, HOMELESSNESS PROBLEM, AND
WHERE ILLEGAL ALIENS ARE TREATED
BETTER THAN POOR VETERANS, IS
GIVING AMERICA A BLUEPRINT OF
HOW NOT TO PROCEED POLICY WISE."
YET DESPITE THIS DISASTROUS
STATE OF AFFAIRS, DEMOCRATS ARE
RUSHING TO EMBRACE THESE
CALIFORNIA VALUES.
>> I THINK THAT ANYONE WHO IS IN
A SITUATION WHERE THEY ARE IN
NEED OF HEALTH CARE REGARDLESS
OF WHETHER THEY ARE DOCUMENTED
OR UNDOCUMENTED, WE'VE GOT AN
OBLIGATION.
THAT'S WHY I THINK WE NEED MORE
CLINICS AROUND THE COUNTRY.
>> I'M OPPOSED TO ANY POLICY
THAT WOULD DENY IN OUR COUNTRY
ANY HUMAN BEING FROM ACCESS TO
PUBLIC SAFETY, PUBLIC EDUCATION,
OR PUBLIC HEALTH PERIOD.
>> Laura: THAT'S NOT ALL.
BERNIE SANDERS ALSO GUARANTEE
THE HEALTH CARE COSTS OF
EVERYONE RESIDING IN THE U.S.
ILLEGAL OR NOT.
JUST REVIEW, SPENDING HUNDREDS
OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS ON
HEALTH CARE OVER THE YEARS
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
REQUIRES ELIMINATING FUNDS THAT
COULD BE USED TO ASSIST AMERICAN
CITIZENS LIVING IN CALIFORNIA,
JUST FOCUS ON CALIFORNIA, THOSE
PEOPLE WHO ARE IN NEED, SO BE
IT.
THAT'S JUST WHAT YOU HAVE TO DO.
BY THE      BY THE WAY, CALIFORI
BY THE      BY THE WAY, CALIFORA
BY THE      BY THE WAY, CALIFORN
BY THE      BY THE WAY, CALIFORT
ALONE.
IN THE STATE OF TEXAS, THEY ARE
SUFFERING FROM A LACK OF
CONGRESSIONAL LEADERSHIP.
WHILE THE PRESIDENT STRUGGLES TO
DEAL WITH AN OVERRUN BORDER,
CONGRESS IS TRYING TO BLOCK HIS
EVERY EFFORT, REFUSING TO
PERFORM A SET OF LAWS TO PROTECT
OUR CITIZENS.
NOW, DID YOU KNOW THAT IN THE
MONTH OF MAY, BORDER PATROL
ARRESTED MORE THAN 132,000
PEOPLE TRYING TO CRASH OUR
BORDER.
IN THE FIRST TWO WEEKS OF JUNE,
MORE THAN 500 AFRICANS HAVE BEEN
ARRESTED TRYING TO SNEAK INTO
THE COUNTRY AS WELL.
THAT'S KIND OF NEW.
NOW, HUNDREDS OF ILLEGALS FROM
THE CONGO APPARENTLY ARE
APPLYING FOR ASYLUM AND BEING
DEPOSITED IN SAN ANTONIO.
NOW, THIS COULD CLEARLY BE A
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERN.
WHY?
ACCORDING TO REUTERS, THE NUMBER
OF CASES OF EBOLA IN EASTERN
CONGO HAS PASSED 2,000.
GOVERNMENT FIGURES SHOWED, AS
THE RATE OF NEW CASES CRIPPLED
AND CONTAINMENT EFFORTS FALTERED
IN THE REMOTE, UNSTABLE REGION.
THE CITY OF SAN ANTONIO GOT BACK
TO "THE INGRAHAM ANGLE" TONIGHT
AND SAID FOR THEM, EBOLA, THEY
DON'T BELIEVE IS A CONCERN.
WHY?
THEY SAY THE INCUBATION PERIOD
IS 21 DAYS FOR THAT DISEASE AND
THAT THEY BELIEVE THESE FOLKS
HAVE BEEN OUTSIDE THEIR COUNTRY
FOR SIX TO SEVEN MONTHS.
BUT I DON'T KNOW.
WHY WOULD WE EVEN PUT THAT THE
CHANCE?
I'M NOT SURE WE ARE REALLY
TRACKING THE TRAVEL PATTERNS OF
EVERYBODY COMING IN THE COUNTRY.
BUT THEY ARE TELLING US DON'T
WORRY TONIGHT.
IT'S OKAY.
I REMEMBER, UNDER CURRENT LAW,
THESE ASYLUM-SEEKERS MUST BE
PROCESSED AND THEN RELEASED INTO
THE MAINLAND UNITED STATES.
LAST WEEK, THE SAN ANTONIO
DEPARTMENT OF HUMAN SERVICES
SENT OUT AN URGENT MESSAGE FOR
FRENCH SPEAKERS TO HELP
TRANSLATE FOR THE CONGOLESE
FAMILIES NOW HOUSED IN A CITY
RUN SHELTER.
ONE WONDERS WHERE IS THE CONCERN
FOR THE HEALTH OF THE
SAN ANTONIO CITIZENRY?
FRANKLY CITIZENS ACROSS THE
UNITED STATES.
WHO'S GOING TO TRANSLATE THEIR
CONCERNS TO FEDERAL OFFICIALS?
AND WHY IS NO ONE QUESTIONING
THE PRESSURE THAT THIS WILL
PLACE ON COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY THAT ARE NOW OBLIGATED
TO HOUSE, EDUCATE, AND FEED
PEOPLE FROM OTHER CONTINENTS